- [Narrator] This is the
Rowley's palm pit viper,
and it's as dangerous as it is rare.
There are 10 species of palm pit viper
that inhabit the cloud
forests of Central America.
But of all of them, the Rowley's
is the most rare and elusive.
It can only be found on
three isolated mountains
in southern Mexico.
Brilliant green and slender,
these vipers will spend
most of their lives,
coiled quietly in trees
and other vegetation.
They are not aggressive by nature,
but will strike if disturbed.
A bite from a Rowley's is not
likely to be fatal to humans,
but be warned, no
specific anti-venom exists
for this extraordinary species of snake.
While not necessarily a threat to us,
those that should be worried
are the small mammals
and tree frogs that the viper preys upon.
Those that stray too close will
meet a swift and silent end.
But even these venomous predators
can't stave off bigger threats.
Deforestation and
over-collection for the pet trade
are perilous threats for this rare animal.
This is the Rowley's palm pit viper.